we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
hey David looking at this terrorist
attack that occurred at ariana grande
concert I'm kind of curious where all of
the crazy right-wing fault was more on
you need to start yelling and screaming
about how Donald Trump somehow
orchestrated this attack to take you
note of it you know they can take the
the basically everyone's eyes off the
investigation with Russia right you know
like they would do with Obama you know
everything was a false flag Sandy Hook
everything was a false flag to try to
keep it down
so we're the conspiracy theory Alex two
nutjobs anyway yeah later
well said I don't have much to add all
of a sudden nobody thinks that there's a
false flag even those same
conspiratorial minds now to be clear I
don't believe that the attack in
Manchester England it was a false flag
but how could it be that you have droves
of right-wingers with Sandy Hook it's a
pretext by Obama to take away guns which
never happened record gun sales gun
sales are down now they're down from
under President Obama and in the midst
of scandal after scandal nobody suggests
maybe there was a false flag here well
now I think that because Alex Jones is
Infowars is getting White House press
credentials yeah they kind of have to
tone it down a bit and not criticize the
president we're gonna talk about that
tomorrow just ran out of time today
we've got a great bonus show for you
today david pakman.com slash membership
sign up coupon code I voted 17 saves you
40% off of the cost of membership